we're here to show our respect for all
women who have a case have it respected
the due process to investigate there's a
lot of excitement around the idea that
women will be heard and be will listen
to it's a great courage for her to come
forward there was never any record and
that nobody ever came forward instead of
asking questions the Republican
leadership fears the truth there is also
due process and the fact that Joe Biden
is Joe Biden Oh Nancy then and Nancy now
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi defending Joe
Biden as he denies a sexual assault
allegation but it was a different tune
for Justice Brett Kavanaugh and in a new
Fox News op-ed senator Marsha Blackburn
calls out the media for the same double
standard senator black at Blackburn
joins us now I had the honor and
privilege of serving with her when she
was in the House of Representatives but
now she is sitting on the very powerful
Senate Judiciary Committee and you saw
up close and personal what happened to
justice Kavanagh yes indeed I did and
what we are just fascinated with right
now is the double standard in Jason I
will tell you so many women that have
reached out to me this week are talking
about fairness and they see a lack of
fairness in this issue around Tara Reid
and they feel as if the me2 movement has
actually served a purpose to make it
easier for their daughters and
granddaughters to say something wrong
was done to me but then they see the
Democrats using me to when it's
convenient and dismissing it when it is
not convenient and I'll tell you
listening to Joe Biden's interview
yesterday I said we should call this the
Pretzel defense he was on every side and
contradicting himself and twisting
himself in knots as he gave that
interview yesterday yeah he can't say it
enough the left
without without double standards the
left probably wouldn't have any
standards now it's not just political
left though they're buddies in the media
taking a very different approach at this
moment take a watch he was incredibly
defiant there's no gray area this is
black and white they simply did not
happen he's called for full transparency
on the records you know that's what
needed to happen
that's what didn't happen let's be clear
in the Cavanaugh hearings the right is
running a smear campaign against Joe
Biden so it's just a smear campaign
against Joe Biden senator you know this
is a very serious issue sexual assault
sexual harassment is a very serious
issue and should be treated as such it
should not be something that is used as
a political football or as a term of
convenience to suit the purposes of the
Democrats they are determined to take
down Donald Trump they do not want
anything to happen to Joe Biden they're
so determined to take down President
Trump that they are actually going to
dismiss someone who has corroborating
evidence she talked to people her mother
called Larry King and we will get to the
bottom of this I think that truth will
come out we know that Vice President
Biden has had a history touching people
and kissing and making them
uncomfortable and even the New York
Times had to go back in and alter an
article that they had put up online
dealing with some of his known behaviors
this is serious
Tara Reid deserves to be heard just like
other women deserves to be heard this
needs to be reviewed and Joe Biden needs
to come forward and just tell the truth
senator let's talk about this for a
second here because as you know dealing
with Iran a virus has become a bit
partisan you could say that the Senate
is returning to work on Monday what do
you see happening this week what we're
going to do is move forward on some of
the work that needs to be done we can
walk and chew gum
time if you will and there are judicial
appointments there are nominations for
the administration that need to be
looked at we're going to have an armed
services hearing and we're going to be
working on on-line privacy and jillian
one of the things that has come forward
through kovat 19 is the lack of online
privacy and the lack of individuals you
and i individually being able to control
what I call our virtual you deciding if
we want to opt in to share information
or not requiring companies to inform us
when they are data mining and reviewing
information from us and this healthcare
privacy which in the physical space is
controlled by HIPAA we're going to have
to look at how this is affecting
individuals online and chairman wicker
at Commerce Committee and a couple of
others of us have legislation that is
being introduced next week to deal with
that we're also going to be turning our
attention to holding holding China
accountable for what they have done
whether it is moving forward with having
China waive the interest payments on
their debt something that I've supported
moving manufacturing back to US soil and
Senator Menendez and I have the Sam C
bill which moves that pharmaceutical
manufacturing back to the US Congress
senator Sullivan and others have other
pieces of legislation that will move
manufacturing back senator mcsalley and
rep Gooden and I have the stop coded act
that will put input into the hands of US
Senate citizens the ability to sue the
Chinese Communist Party for their role
in this pandemic and will give those
individuals that have lost lives and
livelihoods the ability to go into US
courts so all of that will
Genda for this week senator thank you so
much for joining us it's good to see you
and I thought the Senate for being in
session because the house is not going
to be in session and that is just
fundamentally wrong
Gillian Thank You senators thank you
very much